my neighbor is from afghanistan and he
has been
telling me some very horrible things
[Music]
last week as the u.s was leaving
afghanistan after we've been there for
20 years the taliban which is a
political and military group took over
the entire country and eventually made
it to the capital where they ran the
government out of the country and
declared themselves the government of
afghanistan they did this really fast
faster than the u.s thought they would
here's this map by emperor tigerstar
showing just the last few months of
afghanistan going from afghan controlled
which is green
to taliban controlled which is white
cnn cnn
he told me to cover my face one of the
first things the taliban did was hold a
press conference where they assured the
people of afghanistan that they would
not be going after revenge on whoever
worked for the united states or nato or
any other outside country because we
have announced
general amnesty for everyone the
security forces from senior to the
junior level
and this
fear all this hysteria that has taken
place
is unfounded
this right here this is actually what i
want to talk about in this short video
i'm not making an explainer on
afghanistan
i just want to make one thing clear when
i heard the taliban speak in this way
and talk about how they're different now
and how they actually want to build an
inclusive society i wanted to believe
them i think a lot of us wanted to
believe like well what if they have
changed our women have the same rights
they can work in different sectors on
the basis of our rules and regulations
in education and health and other areas
there will be no discrimination against
women but then my neighbor came over
last night he
and his wife and two children moved from
afghanistan just a couple of years ago
they were u.s contractors worked for the
us government and their families are
currently still in afghanistan
i i was
working hardly
to
make something for our community for
ourselves
but
we lost everything
what i learned in this conversation is
that
we should not believe the taliban they
are lying they're putting on a show of
inclusion
and change in the name of trying to get
international recognition for their new
self-declared country but in reality
they are actually seeking revenge
and imposing
their
dogmatic rule on everyone around them
and especially targeting those who were
a part of the us military or civilian
operations
they're going door to door
hunting
for anyone who was involved with the us
which is why you see scenes like this
people fleeing at whatever cost
my brother
he used to work with us government
contracts
direct and indirect since 2010 my
mother-in-law he
worked with u.s government contracts
from 2013 and some other colleagues they
are searching house by house to find
their
targeted people they are saying if you
do not give me
the person who used to work with
this
country we will we are going to kill
like family members
this is what it makes fair to our family
it's easy to read the news and to
package this up in our minds as just an
issue that's happening far away that has
to do with geopolitics and history and
newsy things
but
after talking to my neighbor last night
it was a stark reminder that this is
human lives people who have fled their
homes who are living in hiding
right now who are scared for their lives
children who now live in the shadows and
live in fear and people who will do
anything to escape their country where
they have roots and culture and
connections
it doesn't matter because their life is
in danger that's the reason that they
have moved
from their like permanent resident
and they are living like
few nights one place just to hide out
they are living in fear
and any anytime
evan fb or not
even they are not and they are like
thermal interested in like their own
house
someone is knocking the door they feel
that yeah the taliban is there and they
are coming after them when i think about
my
16 years old sister it's very hard for
me to think about
i'm going to think about how i can tell
the story of afghanistan and how it
turned out like this that is a story
that needs to be told and understood
but today i'm making this video just to
tell you to remember that as you read
about this
and look into it
you should not believe anything the
taliban is saying they're lying
they're lying to deceive all of us
so that they can continue
their brutal rule
towards the people that they now control
i also want you to remember to think of
this not just as another breaking news
bit
but
as real lives
people suffering people living in fear
that's what this story is and it's
playing out right now
[Music]
you